flood waters are coursing through the
state of minas in southeast brazil this
is juartuba one of the towns underwater
over the last two months thousands have
been left homeless across brazil victims
of a relentless rainy season now minas
is bearing the brunt
of the americas
the water level in my house reached my
waist we lost everything my children and
my wife left the house by boat we are
getting the things we managed to save
out of there but clothes and these
things we couldn't really save
and ten people have died in minas in the
last two days
it could get worse this is the karaoke
dam threatening to go down
the dam has never been like this may god
free us and keep us safe if it breaks it
will hurt many people below there are
five cities down there that will be
harmed
indigenous communities in the
it's a very sad feeling one of
heartbreak to see this community in such
a state if it were up to me i would
never return here my heart is bleeding
at the moment they're using a local
school as a shelter all over the state
others are suffering too
and desperately hoping that the rain
stops
john holman al jazeera